hello and thank you for joining us today
for biotech's webinar event
my name is lindsey and i will be the
moderator for today's webinar
the audio for today's webinar will be
coming from your computer speakers
so please be sure they are turned on and
the volume is up to ask a question
please use the chat feature it is
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your screen
you can send in your questions at any
time our speaker will address the
questions during the q a session at the
conclusion of the event
if we do not get to your question we
will do our best to respond by email
today's webinar will be presented by
brad larson principal scientist at
biotech instruments
we'd like to thank him for joining us
today with that i'll turn things over to
brad to get us started
thank you lindsay and good afternoon
everyone uh first of all on behalf of
biotech
and our collaborative companies in this
project corning life sciences
cis bio and ncm i'd like to thank you
for attending uh the webinar today
the goal is to introduce you to combined
solutions that enable the performance of
phenotypic
tumor invasion assays as well as
mechanism of action analyses
that provide high throughput accurate
real-time results
through the incorporation of cellular
imaging and kinetic
microplate reader detection
metastasis or the spread of cancer cells
from
the site of the original tumor to
secondary locations within the body
is linked to approximately ninety
percent of cancer deaths
therefore not surprisingly and it's one
of the most highly studied processes
in all of cancer research however the
development of therapy is designed to
forestall the
metastatic activity of tumors has been
met with multiple challenges
these include the incorporation of
inappropriate tumor cell models
such as but not limited to signal cancer
cell lines plated on the bottom of a
microplate
in a two-dimensional or 2d format
mechanism of
action determinations which do not
include relevant analysis procedures
and inaccurate tracking and
quantification of microscopic tumor
invasion
therefore new cell models and methods of
analysis are required to reduce the
number of failures
once leave molecules reach clinical
trial tumors in vivo exist
as a three-dimensional or 3d mass of
multiple cell types including cancer and
stromal cells
therefore incorporating a 3d spheroid
type
cellulose structure that includes
co-cultured cell types
forming a tumoroid can provide a more
predictive model
than the use of individual cancer cells
cultured in a traditional 2d format
second hurdle as i mentioned previously
is
accurate mechanism of action
determination processing
accurate or possessing accurate
knowledge of how invasion is interrupted
provides
a more complete picture before
proceeding to clinical testing
real-time analysis of matrix
metalloproteinases
activity during the 3d innovation
process
uh following inhibitor addition in
addition to kinetic
examination of inhibitor receptor
resonance
times in comparison to ligands whose
binding is known to contribute to the
metastatic process
also yield a mechanism of action
determinations with a higher degree of
accuracy
these coupled with sensitive detection
and quantification of binding events
changes in tumoroid structures and
protease activity
allow for the generation of in future
results that have a much closer
correlation
to what is then generated during
individual clinical testing
i'll start the introduction to these
combined solutions by first telling you
about the instrumentation
used to carry out the kinetic
determination of receptor ligand
resonance
times and imaging of the 3d tumor
invasion process
followed by the microplate technology
from corning life sciences
incorporated for tumoroid formation and
performance of the 3d tumor invasion
assay procedure
then we'll look at how the citation 5
and spheroid microplates were used
together in combination
with biotech's gen 5 data analysis
software to easily and accurately
observe and quantify changes to the
tumorite structure
following chemoattractants and inhibitor
additions
then finally i'll explain how we were
able to perform
two different types of mechanism of
action evaluation the first
looking at matrix metalloproteinase
activity
during tumor invasion using the incense
technology from enzium
and the second to determine receptor
resonance times of a known ligand and
potential inhibitory compounds
using htrf take light technology from
cisbio
the synergy neo was used to perform the
kinetic microplates
reads necessary to calculate receptor
resonance times
the neo is a multi-mode reader capable
of being used either for screening
or in core laboratories the instrument
contains dual matched pmts above the
plate stage for simultaneous capture of
two separate emission signals
such as the signal from the donor and
acceptor molecules
used in hdrf assays as well as a single
pmt below the
plate stage for use with lysol assays
neo can also be equipped with dual
injectors which
allows for direct dispensing into
microplate wells
while the plate is already in the
reading chamber in the assay performed
here we injected cells
into wells already containing ligand or
ligand and compounds
to allow the binding process to then
begin the combination of these two
features
created an ideal solution for rapidly
capturing the changes in fluorescent
signal from both molecules
as receptor binding occurred
the citation 5 was then used to perform
the cellular imaging
during all tumor invasion assays which
were run
with its digital wide field imaging
capabilities
and multiple multiple imaging modes
including fluorescence bright fields
color bright field and phase contrast
the instrument can be used to capture
images
of a wide variety of samples including
cells plants or insect
sections zebrafish larvae and h e
stained tissues
the citation 5 is also a multi-mode
instrument and contains all the
capabilities of a microplate reader
the filter-based detection system seen
in the upper right-hand corner of the
instrument cutout in blue
is a direct optical system which gives
the greatest sensitivity for use with
weekly fluorescent probes
the monochromator based detection system
seen in the upper left hand corner
and brown gives the greatest flexibility
with the
incorporation of variable band pass
selection a wide range
of wavelengths can be incorporated into
the read step to ensure that the highest
quality results are then achieved
the digital microscopy system seen in
yellow
is then housed below the microplate
stage
here you see a more detailed view of the
inverted fluorescence microscopy system
up to six separate objectives can be
placed into the instrument at a time
ranging from
1.25 to 60x
separate phase objectives can also be
included should phase contrast imaging
be necessary
imaging filter cubes are then used to
provide excitation
and ensure correct wavelength selection
light is emitted
from the colored leds passes through an
excitation
filter and is then piped up through the
objective
to the sample the emission signal then
passes back through the objective
is directed through the emission filter
to the camera
which contains the sony's 16-bit ccd
chip
the led excitation source and filters
are contained in separate parts of the
filter cube which allows
the parts to be interchangeable giving
increased flexibility to
damage a wide variety of fluorescent
probes
gen 5 software is then used to program a
variety of imaging steps
such as single image capture image
montages or z stacking
such as what we're seeing here in this
step multiple images can automatically
be captured at different z
heights through the sample a variety of
algorithms
can then be used to create a projected
image that contains the most
in-focus portions of each individual
image captured
and as you'll see later in the webinar
this can help to ensure that the most
accurate results
are generated from the experimental
procedure
moving on from the instrumentation as
mentioned previously corning spheroid
microplates were then incorporated
into the 3d tumor invasion procedure
the plates utilized corning's ultra low
attachment surface
to prevent cell adhesion to the
microplate
in addition the unique round well bottom
design enables
the positioning and growth of a single
spheroid per well that are uniform
and reproducible in size the microplates
are available in standard sbs footprint
dimensions for 96 and three to four wall
formats
and the clear bottom also allows for
easy visualization and imaging
the extended black side walls also
helped
to reduce crosstalk and background noise
for fluorescent and luminescent based
assays
finally due to the microplate design no
transfer step is necessary
between the completion of spheroid
formation and the beginning
of the assay procedure which can make
the
entire process simpler to to perform
the ultra low attachment surface used in
the plates is a hydrophilic
neutrally charged hydrogel coating that
inhibits specific and non-specific
immobilization
which forces the cells into a suspended
state enabling 3d spheroid formation
the coating is stable non-cytotoxic
biologically inert
and nondegradable shown here is an
example of how cell
morphology and aggregation varies
between different plate coatings and
geometries
on the far left are ht29 cells cultured
for 72 hours and a 96
well tissue culture treated microplates
and as you can see the ceo's the typical
adherent two-dimensional monolayer cells
that we're accustomed to
to seeing upon culture in a flat bottom
ultra low attachment 961 microplate
these cells then begin to form multiple
cell aggregates
however due to the flat bottom
configuration spheroids are non-uniform
in size
which can lead to variability in the
results seen from
treatment of each spheroid as well as
within replicate wells
then finally on the right when the cells
are cultured in the
96 well format of the spheroid
microplates
a single nicely rounded spheroid is
formed in each well this leads to
greater uniformity in the data from
replicate wells and across the entire
plate when used for screening purposes
this slide and then the the video that
i'm going to show next
demonstrates how spheric formation can
easily be tracked
in the wells of the sphere and
microplate using the citation five
this is an example where 5000 hct-116
cells were added to one of the wells of
the spheroid microplate that i just
mentioned and then imaging
was performed once per hour over 24
hours using the citation 5 with the 4x
objectives and here i'll start the video
so again you can see over time how the
cells easily aggregate
into a single spheroid or tumoroid
type of a configuration then following
the completion of aggregation these can
then be used for
performing whatever assay that you see
fit
we then went on to create the following
procedure to perform the entire
multi-day 3d tumor innovation
experimental process
mda mv231 breast cancer cells expressing
gfp
and human dermal fibroblasts expressing
rsp were combined in a one-to-one ratio
and dispensed into the wells of the
spheroid microplates to create a final
concentration of 5000 total cells per
well
following tumoroid formation a portion
of the media was removed and replaced
with media containing chemo attractants
or chemotrichtan and inhibitor
diluted matrigel matrix again containing
either chemoattracted
or chemotracted an inhibitor was then
added on top of the aqueous layer
as an overlay then following
centrifugation
to reposition the tumoroid in the center
of the well
fluorescence and right field imaging was
then performed for the initial time
point
and subsequently repeated on a daily
basis throughout the entire invasion
incubation period
then to make sure that everyone has a
firm grasp of
what's really going on in the well
during this process
i'll go over the procedure one more time
in a more uh pictorial
manner so here we see the again the
empty well of
the spheroid microplate
cells in media are added to the well and
aggregates into the tumeric structure
that you see
in the bottom right corner of the screen
you can also see the distribution of the
gfp expressing
breast cancer cells in rfp expressing
fibroblasts within the total tumoroid
structure
after aggregation is complete seventy
percent of the
spent media is then removed
and replaced with an equal volume of
media containing chemo attractants
diluted nature gel is then added
as an overlay again containing
chemoattractant
acidification in a cooled centrifuge
then repositions the tumeroid in the
center
of the well and initiates the mixing of
the two layers
and again the same procedure is followed
in the case of running an inhibitor
experiment
with the difference being that an
inhibitor is also added along with the
chemoattractant to the aqueous
and matrigel matrix layers image-based
tracking of tumor invasion is then
performed
for either type of experiment on a daily
basis
here in this slide we see an example of
what the tumor innovation process
looks like over a five-day incubation
period
imaging was conducted each day using a
forex objective
of a tumoroid in a well containing the
chemoattractant cxcl12
and no inhibitor each picture is
actually an
overlay of individual images that were
captured using
brightfield gfp and rfp imaging channels
the right field image shows the state of
the entire structure including cells and
invadopodia
while the gfp and rfp images display the
extent of invasion
of either the mb 231 breast cancer cells
or fibroblasts respectively
then through the incorporation of
biosexgen5 software which is used
to not only control the imager but also
contains a data analysis
package the extent of invasion can then
be determined
using internal algorithms in addition to
cellular analysis
parameters such as brightfield signal
threshold
and minimum and maximum object size a
detailed mask
is automatically drawn around the object
that
meets the criteria here you can see
with the arrows the in
gold or yellow with the mask that was
drawn around the tumoroid
initially following chemoattractive
initiate addition
and then following the five day
incubation process
so again as i just mentioned you're
looking at the bright field images
and you see the with the use of
the the object mask that the software
draws
around the object meeting the the
criteria of
the of the different parameters that
were selected and then from the data
generated
we can then perform multiple different
types of analysis
the first uses the area within each
object
mask and the second uses the
total bright field signal within the
object
and those are shown in the two graphs to
the right
of the images that you see here and here
and what i've done for each graph is to
plot either the area or bright field
signal within
the object on each successive day as you
can see by the bars
in red and then the valleys are plotted
using the um the left y-axis and i've
also computed a ratio of the values from
days one through five compared to the
value
from day zero to normalize the results
those are seen in green
and are plotted on the y the right y
axis
and then with either type of evaluation
it's obvious that the tumoroid
is invading at a high level through the
matrix over the total incubation period
this type of analysis is useful if the
cells
you're using do not express any
fluorescent proteins or if there's a
desire to not include any type of
fluorescent probe
such as a long-term tracker dye and in
this way this then is a truly label-free
type of analysis
however if the cells you were using do
express
fluorescent protein or a fluorescent
probe
has been added here again as i mentioned
the
breast cancer cells are gfp expressing
the signal
from that the fluorescent
probe can also be used to track invasion
here we're seeing again in images from
the signal of
the the gfp expressing breast cancer
cells which are captured
using the gfp imaging filter cube and
the advantage here is that you can
examine the extent of invasion
specifically for this particular cell
type
the same types of cellular analysis
performed using the bright field
signal to draw the object mask
can then also be performed using the gfp
signal again we see images captured on
day 0
and day 5 with the object mask
automatically drawn
the graphs on the top right shows the
area
within all the masks drawn around the
images captured on each subsequent day
of
incubation as well as the ratio of areas
compared to day
zero then if we look at the graph on the
bottom right we can see the comparison
of the area ratios generated using
either the bright field or the gfp mask
which again allows you to see
how the migration of the breast cancer
cells compares to the total invasion of
the tumorite structure
while using single z-plane images is an
easy
and rapid way to perform the analysis of
tumor invasion it may not always provide
the most accurate results due to the
fact that invasion is taking place
not only in the x and y axes but also in
the z-axis
to overcome this complication a
z-stacking imaging step
can be performed in gen 5. here multiple
images are captured at successive
z planes to ensure that different areas
of the structure
are in focus with at least one image
algorithms
can then be used to create a z projected
final image
that contains the most in focus portions
of each pixel
included in the image
and here in this next video clip
what you're seeing are images are
different bright field images
that were captured focusing on it on
a number of different z planes and
obviously it's plain to see that not all
of the parts of the entire structure are
in focus
in any individual image that was
captured
then if we look at the final projected
image it's easy to see how a much more
in-focus
image is of the tumeroid structure
and this can then yield the most
accurate results when
performing the cellular analysis to
measure invasion
and finally the extent of migration for
each cell type co-cultured into the
tumor right structure can also be
examined
here again we see z projected overlaid
images of our tumoroid
on day zero seen here and then on
day five and then with the use of the
line profile tool
we can draw a line from one side of the
image
to the other uh through the tumeric
structure
and the bright fields or fluorescent
signal captured from each
channel within each pixel is then
plotted in the graphs
that you see here again from the tumor
and day zero
and then here from the tumoroid on day
five
on day zero we can see the extent of the
signal
in micrometers covered by the gfp
expressing breast cancer cells and rfp
expressing fibroblasts
matches up precisely to each other
as well as with the total area of the
tumorite as we can see with the with the
bright field signal
however after five days of incubation
when we perform the same type of
analysis
it's clear that the breast cancer cells
which you can see with the green line
have migrated to a much greater extent
than
the fibroblasts so again it allows you
to
to get a clear determination of how each
co-cultured cell type is is uh migrating
in response to the chemoattractant or
chemoattractant and inhibitor that's
been added
moving on from the initial invasion
analysis
we also performed two different types of
mechanism of action studies
uh as not only is it critical to examine
the phenotypic
invasive properties of cells and the
erupt interruption of that invasion
but it's also important to evaluate the
different enzymes and binding activities
that could potentially be involved in
the innovation process
in the first that we're showing here
involved monitoring the activity of
matrix metallo
metalloproteinases or mmps that have
been shown to play a role in the tumor
invasion process
this was done using a novel protease
activity
detection technology from enzyme called
nsense
the assay technology based on a
proprietary protein
substrate which contains a selective
recognition sequence
for a specific protease in addition to a
fluorogenic dye
works in the following manner first as
we see
in the first cartoon the horseshoe
shaped
substrate and dye are added to the well
second
in the presence of the appropriate
protease
the substrate is cleaved exposing the
dye binding site that you see here
and then upon binding of the
of the dye a far red shifted signal is
then created
therefore little to no fluorescence is
seen when the substrate is not in the
presence
of the correct protease
the assay components were able to be
incorporated into the existing 3d tumor
invasion procedure
in a simple straightforward manner the
substrates
and dye as you can see here were added
to the diluted matrigel matrix
containing chemoattractants or again
chemotractan and inhibitor
after addition to the aqueous slater and
centrifugation the components
disseminate through the
entire area surrounding the tumoroid in
this way
as the active proteases begin to cleave
through the matrix the substrate is also
cleaved which allows for binding of the
dye
and an increase in the red signal being
emitted from those portions of the well
the first step in the project was to
test the ability of the assay components
to work properly
within the context of the 3d tumor
invasion model as i just
explained in the previous slides the
mmp14
substrate was selected for inclusion as
this particular mmp has been
shown in the literature to play a
critical role in conferring
cells with the ability to penetrate the
extracellular matrix
and is directly linked to tumor tumor
genesis
and metastasis again here we see
images that were captured over a
multi-day
incubation period starting from day zero
through day five this is again
specifically of
the red signal emitted with the binding
of the dye
to the substrate the sci-fi
imaging cube was used to properly excite
and capture the emitted
signal from the die as this is a red
shifted
die and at times the signal from these
dyes
in its wavelength range can be somewhat
weaker than dyes
in the blue or green range we chose to
perform the imaging
using 10x magnification instead of 4x
this allowed us to be able to capture
the signal
from the dye with greater sensitivity
than would have otherwise been achieved
however since the invading tumeric
structure covers a large
area of the well as you've seen in the
previous slide
multiple images were were needed to
capture
the entire structure and we accomplished
this by performing a montage imaging
step
and then automatically having the images
stitched back together
into the final pictures that you see
here in the slide
and as you can see as is expected we
start out with
a minimal signal on day zero immediately
with the images that was captured
immediately after
the chemo attractant and inhibitor and
the major gel matrix
and then this signal dramatically
increases
over time until after a six day
incubation we see a very
dramatic increase in the signal being
emitted from a large
area of the of the tumor right structure
as matrix metalloproteinases have been
shown to be active
in the invadopodia portion of the
tumoroid structure
specifically mmp14 we also compared
the total coverage of the observed
signal
from the dye to that of the complete
structure by overlaying the sci-5
and bright field images which is what
you're seeing
in the image here
and again as you can see from this image
on the left the extent of coverage
observed uh
with with both uh cy5 and
with the brightfield signal match up
quite well showing
that the mmp14
proteinase is active in
pretty much every area of the invading
tumeric structure
then if we look closer at the images
on the right shown here highlighted with
the yellow areas and then shown here
as well as as multiple areas with this
picture we can also see that the signal
increases
in the invadopodia meaning that mp14
is indeed quite active in these
leading portions of the invading tumeric
structure
uh we can also perform uh cellular
analysis
using the sci-fi signal from the die and
uh as you can see here and with both the
uh the images and the graphs that i'm
showing on this slide
the object masks are drawn in a manner
similar to what i
explained previously so again you're not
using gfp
or right field signal but actually using
specifically the sci-fi
signal to have gen 5 draw the object
masks
around the around the
parts of the tumorite structure meeting
the analysis criteria
then using the results that were
calculated we can compare
either the area covered shown in the
graph on the left
or the total sci-fi signal seen here on
the graph on the right
within each object mask this then allows
you to specifically quantify
the extent of mmp activity
over time
the next step once we confirm that the
assay was performing correctly and
signal was indeed observed in the
expected areas of the structure
was to add an mmp inhibitor to confirm
that cleavage of the substrate was
indeed from mmp activity
and not from being in the presence of
the components
of the major gel matrix here we used gm
6001
which is a broad spectrum mmp inhibitor
the inhibitor was added as i previously
explained
and as you can see from the images shown
here
there is a concentration dependent
decrease in the signal
from the mmp 14 substrates and
dye the signal is never completely
eliminated however as the original
tumeroid is never completely destroyed
which is similar to what has been
observed in vivo and is most likely
due to the fact that the interpreter
does not completely
penetrate the tumorite
the extent of inhibition can then be
quantified once again
using the same type of analysis
procedures that i've
that i've mentioned and confirms again
that interruption of invasion
as well as inhibition of mnp 14 activity
is indeed concentration dependent as you
can see here with a decrease
both in the area of the
of the tumeroid that you see the red
signal
as well as an actual decrease in the
signal
captured with the sci-5 imaging cube
with
increasing concentrations of the gm 6001
and shown with the decrease in the
values in the two graphs
and this can accurately also be um
be detected and measured through the
incorporation
of the citations 5 and the gen
5 data analysis software
the last step in the project was to
confirm that we were seeing
selective cleavage of the added
substrate and
subsequent signal generation from the
target mmp
here we incorporated selective
substrates
for mmp14 and mmp2
as well as the no pro substrate which is
cleaved by yeast protease
and which is not expressed in mammalian
cells
which obviously made it an ideal
negative control substrate to use in
this case
two different types of inhibitors were
tested
again gm 6001 the broad range mmp
inhibitor
and oredonin which is a selective
inhibitor
for mmp2 and mmp9
and if we look at the results first for
gm-6001
on the left here with these graphs
we see that the compound inhibits
substrate cleavage
and subsequent signal production in a
dose-dependent manner
when both mmp2 or
mmp14 substrates are incorporated and
you can see here with the decrease
again in um both in the sci-fi
signal from the um that was included in
the
the masks that were drawn around the
objects both for m
p14 here and then mmp2
then if we look at the results from
oredonin shown here on the right
again the scifi signal is inhibited in a
dose-dependent manner
when the mmp2 substrate is added
shown here again you can see at the
similar type of
shape and descending uh
values of sci-fi signal similar to what
we saw
here with gm 6001 however
when the mmp-14 substrate was
incorporated
shown here no discernible inhibition is
seen until the highest concentration
was reached which is approximately 30
micromolar
and by looking at other images that were
captured
from that well the loss in signal was
determined by us to be
uh from a site of toxic effect from the
compound
and not due to true inhibition which
agrees with published uh literature
stating that ourodonin
exhibits an apoptotic effect on mda
mb231
breast cancer cells and then finally if
we look at the results from the
no pro substrate with each compound
shown by the two graphs here
we see that only low levels of signal
are generated which would indicate that
the substrate is not being cleaved
in any appreciable manner
then a final confirmation that was
performed to
help ensure that the decrease in
sci-fi signal was not just from the fact
that the object mask was decreasing
in size upon increasing compound
concentration
was to look at the total sci-fi signal
generated
within the entire image so this is a
different type of analysis that i've
been showing
to you where we're not drawing any
object masks
around any portions of the tumeric
structure but looking at the actual
total cy5 signal that would be emanating
from the
from the entire image so closer to the
type of analysis that
you would use for a typical microplate
read using a pmt type of technology
as i mentioned this eliminates the use
of the cellular mask
and incorporates the signal from every
pixel and again
we see the same types of decrease in
signal
with both the mp14 and mmp2
substrate with increasing gm 6001
concentrations as you see here with the
with the graph on the left however the
the dose dependent decrease with the
addition of aurodonin is only seen
in the results from the mmp 2 substrate
shown
in blue and then again there's really no
appreciable change
shown with the bars in red from the mmp
14 substrate and this again confirms
that accurate results can be achieved
when combining the incense
assay components with the 3d tumor
invasion procedure
the second mechanism of action project
was performed to study the correlation
of ligand binding to the cxcr4 chemokine
receptor
as well as interruption of that binding
and then how it relates to the final
invasive phenotypic effect the
expression of
cxcr4 is tightly correlated
with the metastatic properties of breast
cancer cells
and in vivo neutralizing the interaction
of cxr
cxcr4 with its known ligand sdf1 alpha
also known as cxcl12
significantly impaired the metastasis of
breast cancer cells and cell migration
traditionally the discovery of novel
agents has been guided
by the affinity of the ligand for the
receptor under equilibrium conditions
largely ignoring the kinetic aspects
of the ligand receptor interaction
however awareness of the importance
of binding kinetics has started to
increase due to the accumulating
evidence suggesting
that the individual effectiveness of
ligands may be attributed
to the time a particular ligand resides
at its receptor or otherwise known as
the drug target resonance time
due to these findings in this project
we examine the drug target residence
time of
various cxr4 inhibitors in relation to
the known ligands
using the tablite direct homogeneous
receptor ligand binding assay that you
see here
from cis bio and in general the assay
works
in the following manner cells are
engineered to express the receptor of
interest which you see here
which contains a snap tag labeled
with a terbium molecule
a labeled ligand shown here is then
added to the well
and as binding occurs energy is
transferred from
the donor floor to the acceptor
and and then this causes the ratio of
the signal
from the acceptor compared to the donor
floor
to then increase the ratio continues to
increase as the number of binding events
also increase eventually reaching a
plateau over time which again
as previously mentioned is usually what
has been
monitored with these types of assays
then if a molecule is introduced such as
shown here in green
is uh introduced to the well which
interrupts the binding
uh this molecule preferably uh
preferentially binds to the receptor
uh kicks off the labeled ligand and
uh fret does not occur and then the
ratio
of the acceptor to the donor floor
then decreases subsequently
the final residence time value takes
into account
the observed on and off rates of the
unlabeled
inhibitors obviously and is computed by
the incorporation of the mitulski and
man equation
the on and off rates of the labeled
ligand are also necessary
components of the equation therefore
an association associative binding
experiment was first performed
using the acceptor floor labeled ligand
that i just
talked about previously then by plotting
the htrf ratios
those values over time for each of the
ligand concentrations tested which you
see
with all the different curves that have
been plotted here
the observed binding values or the k obs
can then be generated
the kd value of the ligand can also be
determined
by plotting the htrf ratios generating
after a binding equilibrium was reached
again as i showed here therefore the
the final hdf ratios would be used in
from this portion
of the curve and then plotted here
to generate the kd value that is
that is then shown we were also able to
confirm the law
of mass action by plotting the
calculated
observed association binding values or
the chaos values
that's shown here on the graph on the
right
in relation to ligand concentration
and observing a linear relationship
between the two as you can see here the
association
and uh dissociation rate constants
or the k on and the k off
using the linear regression regression
line that was calculated
can can then be generated
the resonance time of the unlabeled
inhibitor panel
was then determined in the subsequent
experiment
here the labeled ligands and unlabeled
competitors were added to the well at
the same time
and then co-incubated with the cxer for
expressing
cells during a kinetic association
experiment
from the curve fitting and the
mitalskiyan man
equation that i mentioned previously the
k on
and chaos kinetic constants of the
unlabeled competitors
were then generated as you can see here
the resonance times shown with the
values that i've circled
in red were then derived by dividing one
by the chaos value these values were
then compared to the resonance time
of the labeled ligand which you see here
from these values as well as from the
shape of the curves for the
concentrations of inhibitor tested
qualitative assumptions regarding the
constant can then be made
first if the competitor dissociates
faster
than its target from its target than the
ligand such as we see here
in the results when testing amd 3100
and wd811 the
specific binding of the ligand will
slowly
and monotonically approach its
equilibrium time and this then leads to
low resonance time such as the values
that are shown here
however when the competitor
dissociates slower such as we see with
amd 3465
and it1t the association curve of the
ligand will consist
of two distinct phases starting with a
typical overshoot such as what you see
here and here and then to decline
until a new equilibrium is released is
reached
such as we see here compounds whose
resonance
times are greater again
which we see by the residence times
generated for these two compounds
again these the values that are greater
than that of the known ligand
which was 0.44 for the labeled sdf1
alpha
may then exhibit a stronger inhibitory
response
when used in the confirmatory phenotypic
assay
which is then what we went on to perform
the inhibitor panel used in the
residence time study was then
run with the 3d tumor invasion assay
procedure such as i previously described
in the presence of a single
concentration of unlabeled
sdf1 alpha and here you can see
an example of the co-culture tumoroid
structures
again on day zero and then
after a five-day incubation in the
presence
of the chemoattractant and either amd
3465
which is shown by the images on the top
here
or in the presence of ctce 9908
such as the image you see on the bottom
whose residence time was shorter than
that of the ligand
and by the images that were captured of
the tumeric structures
in the presence of amd 3465 it's a plane
to see that the compound is exhibiting
a dose-dependent inhibition of final
tumor
tumor invasion whereas again ctce 9908
whose resonance time value was shorter
than that of the ligand exhibits
no discernible inhibitory effect on
invasion
at any of the concentrations that were
tested
the effect of rhythms time was further
confirmed by observing the results from
all six of the compounds that were
tested
it1t again whose resonance time is
longer than that of the ligand similar
to amd 3465
also inhibits invasion in a
dose-dependent manner such as what you
can see
here again similar to amd 3465
while all the other compounds that were
tested
exhibits really little or no ability to
interrupt invasion
through the 3d matrix and that's shown
by the results that you see with these
four graphs here
so in conclusion the slides and results
that i've shown today
hopefully confirm how proper
instrumentation
microplates cell models assay
chemistries and testing procedures
can provide combined processes that are
both easy to perform
provide and provide accurate
reproducible data to better understand
the target-based and phenotypic effects
of potential inhibitors of tumor
invasion and metastasis
if you'd like any additional information
specific
to all the different pro products that
were mentioned here
you can find that information by going
to
one of the websites that's listed here
specifically for each of the
of the different companies
so it looks like we have a little bit of
time to
to go and look at a few of the questions
that have
come in during the presentation so i'll
i'll do that now before we before we
finish up the first one
uh states when the um the spheroid is
first introduced
into the well do you centrifuge the
plate
and at what time and duration did you
take so
the answer is yes so it's important to
remember that
um for centrifuging the microplates
the the centrifuge should be cooled down
um
if you've ever you know dealt or had to
use
major gel obviously you'll know that
it's extremely
important to keep the the matrix cool
so that it does not begin to gel
uh you know prior to you know when it's
been
uh properly positioned uh within the
well
so the uh the centrifuge was cooled down
to
uh to four degrees celsius uh prior to
the centrifugation process
and then um the
for centrifugation i
usually would uh would spin the plates
for
uh just a matter of um a minute or two
uh typically at about 200 times
times g again in a swing buckets
rotor type of type of a centrifuge this
obviously
can be optimized depending on the type
of centrifuge that you have
in your lab and uh you know also
depending on the type of
cell models that you are that you're
using
okay the second is do you have a list of
cell lines
uh responsive to cxel12 in this assay
other than mda mb231
um i i do not uh what we did was this
this project was run
as a example or a confirmatory type of a
project to show
that this type of assay could be
performed
you know in cooperation with
or or with the inclusion of the spheric
microplates
the citation imager
the software and then the different
types of assay
essay kits that were
included but i'm i'm sure
that uh through different types of
literature searches that different types
of cell models could then
be identified that are truly
uh responsive to the um to cxcl12 as a
chemo attractant
uh the next one is how many and sense
substrates are available that question
is best
answered by the experts at
enzium labs and again you can go to
their
website as i've shown here under the
additional resource slide and they have
a nice list of the different
uh substrates that are currently
available
uh to use with the uh with the assay
uh and then
then the next question is uh
how deep can the microscope image uh
inside of the tumor spheroid
that's a good question and
as i mentioned previously this is a wide
field type of
microscopy so the
the actual uh amount of penetration
of the light into the tumoroid structure
is
is not going to be
[Music]
as complete as other types of microscopy
however uh with this type of
uh of assay again we're looking
at um you know invasion that's moving
out in all uh axes
so um therefore you know again with this
type of analysis
in my opinion the the actual penetration
or the
you know the ability to um to actually
see the uh the inside you know the true
inside of
the tumoroid structure is probably not
going to be
as critical as with other types of
uh cell analysis that incorporate uh
different uh 3d type of of structures
so that again the the type of analysis
and the the z projection images
that we are able to create using the
citation 5
and the gen 5 analysis
should indeed be able to give you again
a nice accurate
account of the invasion that's going on
within the wells
and then the let's see
i think that's about all the the
questions that i see
um at this time if we do see others come
in we will
certainly uh pass those on either either
i will
answer them myself or i will do my best
to pass them on
again to our friends at uh corning nzm
and cis bio to make sure that uh the
answer the
question is being answered uh in the
best way possible
so with that i will turn it back over to
lindsay
great well thank you very much for
joining us today and thank you to brad
for his presentation and for taking time
to answer some questions
we will email this recorded event to all
participants if you have further
questions for our speaker or would like
more information on biotech's products
please visit our website in addition
please check out our blog like us on
facebook and follow us on twitter to
hear more about biotech webinars or to
learn about our products
and how they can help you again thanks
for joining us